there's a grand spa that i drove by i
think it's on third street that
that's a spot
open 24 hours a day you could go there
in the middle of the night
[Laughter]
hey everybody producer grant here again
uh this is part two of a two-part
episode with polly shore so if this
you're just listening to this one stop
go back listen to last week's episode
there's a direct continuation of the
conversation uh and it's probably one of
the best ones we've had so far so uh
thanks for checking it out
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
with me george lopez
let's do
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
because when you go on stage you go on
with half material and then half you
come up with it on stage or it depends
but you you do come up with it on screen
yeah do come up with those things yeah
yeah
but um everybody's going up is that your
phone who is that i don't know dude it's
a disco light
[Laughter]
um
yeah
the you have a you know you're a father
as well too right of course i got seven
kids
well back in the 90s you know like when
i was on tour you know back on the you
know i had [ __ ] seven kids yeah so
that's what i was saying i got a kid in
atlanta
named katrina i got whitney in in uh
in albuquerque
and i got little caleb in uh in denver
and then i got uh harry over in boston
and i don't have any kids
but if he does he has the [ __ ] names
already
that's where he can plot it on the map
and
you're [ __ ] everywhere
no uh my mom was my kid for many years
and yeah and my um
my work and my comedy and in this [ __ ]
is my kid that's where my heart is so
and you know women in no disrespect to
women but you know everyone needs
attention you're in a relationship and
it's a it's a very much um
uh i assume it's a very give and take
and i'd rather just kind of focus on my
love which is making people happy i
think that's a good yeah that's a good
thing
because i don't want any distractions my
mom never supported comedians having
kids
you know she was always like don't do it
it's gonna [ __ ] ruin you
yeah
you know well it's different because
you're not as you're not as free to
leave
as you would be if you're kind of alone
if you want to get somewhere faster go
alone and then all yes and then also um
you know if you get lonely you just
stick the pillow in between your legs
and you got your dog on the floor and
what's you know i got a beautiful dog my
dog's amazing you sleep with a pillow
between your legs yes one of those long
ones or a long one yeah yeah yeah you
ever do that it's like it's i think it's
a pillow meant for people that sleep
without you know it's a dog a male or
female
it puts you in the spoon position and
you can put it between your legs very
comforting man yeah no i mean i sleep
with the pillow between my legs and my
dog on the floor and i got the love
and if i get lonely i just say hey
you're lonely get over it yeah you know
what i mean like stop being a little
[ __ ] how close did you come to getting
married
um one time a long long time ago but
that was that wasn't you know it was
like in my 20s yeah but um
you know i don't know i also my parents
divorced when i was three and my dad was
unfaithful to my mom and my mom was
dating [ __ ] several comedians and
then obviously the comedians were messes
so i didn't i didn't really see it you
know it wasn't really in
my dna yeah you know um
to to uh settle down and get married so
i don't know maybe in the future do the
comedy stores stay in the family yeah
yeah you've been in the comedy store
which one
don't there's two of them there's one in
san diego and then there's one in uh the
one in san diego sandy yeah san diego
and then uh l.a yeah
one in san diego's that's nice
yeah i just love going i i i
before i had met you i told you i'd
spent i'd seen you at least five times
live yeah and and i go see i just love
laughing i love going to see community
it's such a great thing you know it is
you know
you still work the road right uh-huh a
lot or medium or medium okay
but no better than yeah i mean that you
know i was with uh was it brian dorfman
you know at zane i was with him like a
couple weeks ago and and we're having
lunch and and he says you know i talk
about you know touring and stuff like
that and and every comic is the same
it's you know they they pay us to travel
right
you know because no one wants to go to
the [ __ ] airport no one wants to stay
in hotels no one wants to [ __ ]
you know that the the the performance is
the easy part right the stand-up is the
easy part because when you're on that
stage then you say to yourself [ __ ] now
i know why i [ __ ] flew to nashville
right yeah you know what i mean because
it's beautiful
one time i was doing a
fundraiser so i came into the back house
a little bit late the show already
started
and when i went out there you could hear
somebody go
so i'm like hey man shut up
uh unbeknownst to me it was for a
uh no head trauma oh
[Applause]
fundraiser
wow
i went like this you see my phone
they were all they were all uh had
suffered head trauma oh boy and they
apparently were having a good time
well that's good so i always know they
say know your audience i came in there
i couldn't see anything i just heard
somebody like ah
that happened uh
get into that that happened your [ __ ]
together man at a luncheon for
for kids special needs kids yeah
and i remember sheriff baca was up there
talking towards one of these kids
and that was screaming and they finally
had to just kind of move out kind gently
is it the hardest thing to do you think
of all the performances
you think of singing and dancing do you
think comedy is the hardest to do not
for me
i've been doing it for so long that's a
great answer not for me
not for me but i understand i am a
church people amateurs like i'm more
comfortable on stage than i am like in a
room of of people like when i'm on stage
i feel like more relaxed i grew up yeah
yeah but it's also who i am you know
whether i grew up in it or not like i i
feel like i'm a true stand-up like i
really like being on stage
you know i love it it's like the
you know you got to go to the comedy
store man
it's legendary historic it's great then
i see you're going to be in brea
um no i'll be at flappers tomorrow
tomorrow um i'll be in the small room i
got a one-man show i've been working for
a while so that's going good yeah that's
that's basically all the stuff about the
store that everyone wants to know so
yeah i've been working that for a while
yeah were you involved in the showtime
comedy store special um i'm in it and i
helped with it you know yeah i think
there's better stories than that yeah i
mean i think you you hold a lot of yeah
i have i have i have my own stuff i have
a memoir i have my documentary i have my
one-man show i have all my stuff that
i'm working on so probably next year the
year after it's all going to start
coming you know before social media when
you had to go
to a club you know like if you were a
singer in a band or something
the noise that
would come out of the comedy store when
like you say robin williams went up
there
and or somebody
you know eddie murphy eddie murphy was
[ __ ] like
that dude who had the biggest applause i
think eddie because eddie would roll in
in the 80s and he was almost like every
you ever see footage of like the saudi
arabian princes you know where they'd
kind of roll up in the rolls-royce
there's like 10 of them that's how eddie
would roll you know with his crew he was
like a prince he was like a saudi
arabian prince of comedy and he came on
stage and it was like you couldn't
believe it i was like whoa whoa yeah
yeah you know pretty [ __ ] amazing he
wasn't i mean he is he was an amazing
comic they were at the store and you
would hear it you would hear stuff even
before the internet do you hear you know
when kennison was out there they go oh
we went to go see some dude man at the
comedy store man he goes last it's late
yeah he goes last
and he's he was [ __ ] hilarious yeah
and a good dude too
yeah good dude sam or eddie uh sam eddie
too but but uh sam yeah and dice dice
too right did they go they got along at
first right
um
how did those guys fall out too much of
this they're not saying sam fought with
everyone because sam was on coke
and he was you know insecure and kind of
fearful like he even started [ __ ]
[ __ ] with me
right like i started coming up and i was
like hot on mtv and and i was actually
on arsenio
um it's funny i just saw this this tape
and i was on arsenio
because sam and dice were at it
and then i told i was like i wish sam
would be nicer to dice and da da and
then you know and then and then arsenio
brought that up to sam was hilarious he
goes you know paulie shore was was here
last week and he wished you would be
next nicer to dice and sam goes who
publisher the gilligan of the 90s
[Laughter]
it was hilarious but he was starting to
feel like a little jealous and a little
like angry like if he would have [ __ ]
if sam would have lived dude i bet like
because he never he never saw all my
movies he never saw that run he just saw
me on empty he would [ __ ] die well i
don't know if he would ever you know if
he would have been jealous or like she's
hit on me i think he would have been
jealous yeah he would have [ __ ] on me
for sure sure
he [ __ ] on everyone that [ __ ] started
doing good around bobcat golf wait [ __ ]
him he's up he steals my [ __ ] oh oh the
[ __ ] uh
yeah i did this thing which is hilarious
i was showing these guys before you
showed up i did a uh
um uh like a a
zoom podcast interview thing called
comedians that babysat me and it's
basically me and all these lookalikes so
for the last like six seven months i've
been looking for look-alikes because i'm
in vegas and vegas is like print the
prince look alike the elvis
the michael jackson i'm like where the
[ __ ] comedian look alike right joan
rivers and sam and robin and so i found
these four comics i found a whoopee i
found a [ __ ] uh a robin a sam
kennison and uh a roseanne so i
interviewed them as their my really the
babysitters and i and i i talked to them
but it wasn't robin that passed away it
was just like just treating him like
robin once yeah and when i'm
interviewing these people it's [ __ ]
hilarious because they all are like
locked in and you almost think it's
believable because i grew up with these
guys yeah you know and um but uh um i
don't know what i was saying i was just
saying the um the look-alikes you know
yeah i was at the comedy store
on sunset when
it was a monday and then the guy goes up
and says this woman is from denver and
this wednesday she's going to be on the
tonight show for the first time johnny
carson yeah roseanne barr yeah she went
up there and she had the
for about the first 30 seconds she's
like i never go anywhere i never go and
for her [ __ ] set was yeah
[ __ ] killer man yeah it was and i
said i'm gonna i'm gonna watch her on
wednesday i saw on wednesday she [ __ ]
killed one when you got your show uh the
first show the sitcom no how did how did
you get it did you get it on on uh
are you doing six minutes on one of the
late night shows and then no no i saw
you uh somebody brought a year was your
sit your first sitcom 2002. and that was
your first one yeah that was the truth
yeah and what channel was that on abc
wow big one and how many years was that
on
six that's a big that's a how many how
many did you do 120. so you got some
it's still on yeah what's your sign
what's your date of birth right between
the two no that's exactly that's got to
check for a million dollars last week
really
that's hilarious
god bless you brother that's [ __ ]
great
to get paid for work you already did
yeah
[Laughter]
that's why seinfeld was the king you
never think it's going to go wrong and
you never think it's just or you never
think it's going to happen yeah and when
it does you don't want it to go away you
guys
you got to stay in there as long as you
possibly can yeah
because if you're not in there it'll be
somebody else
yeah good for you yeah yeah no that was
that was a great a great run and and you
know and the fact that you made it past
100 episodes
were you at woodstock 99
i was not
no i saw that mtv
woodstock 99 on hbo that was some oh
[ __ ] that was some limp biscuit [ __ ]
yeah yeah i was hanging out with friends
they [ __ ] hated it
they [ __ ] hated carson carson i mean
it was a different
different time there when it just
started to gradually go
what was the opposite of woodstock it
was the opposite of woodstock yeah
it's almost like hollywood's the
opposite of hollywood now
right fred durst was good in that and
also when he's dressed up like his dad
last summer
yeah that was awesome with the with like
the shooting glasses and the goatee and
the jacket
they were good man yeah it's really good
i never got into them biscuit but that
they had a [ __ ] great setback some
nice music
yeah their stuff's hot
it was all that [ __ ] that aggression
stuff man
but a lot of rock guys everybody went to
the comedy store
oh uh uh slash
all the guys would go see would go see
sam kinderson
um
all those all the bands right up the
street was you know the roxy and the
rainbow rainbow but the comedy store was
the equivalent of having a
a rock club for comedians that guys
would go in there
everybody it was awesome when i was
younger i didn't spend much time on the
west side you know the west side was far
away from this
mexican on the east side of town
so i didn't start going there until
later on so it was all comedy so how's
los feliz for you
it's [ __ ] sick right yeah i like it i
always wanted to live there it's [ __ ]
great it's really nice it's good so many
good restaurants
are you married with kids you're solo
right oh yeah i'm so low yeah how many
kids do you have i just have one how old
wow
sounds like jack what i'm not going i'm
not going i know
are you happy
i don't think i'm going
i don't think i'm going down that road
again
so was it was it a harsh ending
no i just think you know i just think
it's i you know i think when women
sometimes if they see you
and you and
you you don't grind at anything they
think they they need to help you like i
don't really
grind at any of my work i've been doing
it for so [ __ ] long i know what i
have to do yeah but but to them it might
look like i'm not doing anything
and then they all eventually come around
and try to raise me sure or try to tell
me how to be okay amen and i'm not i'm
not doing that yeah are you listening
out there
you get like you get massages you get
massages
you have like a masseuse that come over
now you're not technology yeah
it's good reflexology and then what
about the spa you go to spa and relax
because i go to the spa with bobby lee
all the time oh that's kind of bobby
the korean spa
you should go to the korean spot dude
the grand one the big one it doesn't
matter there's 50 of them hey you're a
better one
they're right what are they doing there
they
i don't do anything i just go steal
steam and sauna and go in the cold pool
and you know you do it for 45 minutes
and you're good there's a grand spa that
i drove by i think it's on third street
that
that's the spot
open 24 hours a day you could go there
in the middle of the night you can get
it it's really good for you yeah
yeah you have to check them off
i want bobby lee to give me a
recommendation where we're going to go
you know i went to one of those spas i
i've always been afraid
the stigma i go in there because i'm an
old cop i'm going to go in there and
somebody's going to be whacking me off
and somebody's going to come in here
you're busted you know as a prostitute
so i went in in vegas my wife dropped me
off with another friend she dropped me
off because my my back was my neck was
really sore i went in there i came out
she says how did he go i said i want to
kick the [ __ ] out of that bruh she
[ __ ] hurt the [ __ ] out of me
so it wasn't it wasn't that good you
know you're not used to it no i don't
know
my whole life listen if you ever go to a
massage place and while you're laying
there you see a couple of like bars yeah
that's good that's that's it that it
means they're gonna [ __ ] hold on that
[ __ ] bar and put their heels into
your shoulders and your back
and they use those things as weight
leverage to go down and and
if you can take it
it feels good what about you don't want
to get jocked up after that you're like
your dick is like
can you take it are you face down or
face up
face down
yeah
yeah you don't do face up
what about weed you smoke weed a little
bit not not the actual flower but what
about gummies yeah they're great right
they are great you got to go to mota
have you been to mota where's that it's
right in silver lake
you know what mota means yeah what does
it mean
wheat yeah
with a couple of [ __ ] huh well i know
that's why i just you know i'm saying
you should go it's right in your hood
yeah do you smoke
sometimes
but a gun is i like me yeah i've been
sleeping on those uh i've been sleeping
punch edibles right is that the one the
punch edibles are good
which one is that uh brand i think
they're screwed punch comedian frank
castillo i don't know if you know he was
on here dude he works with them a bunch
hooked us up with something they're good
you take the multiballs
multiballs i'll take a multiball to go
you're a cop you can't have weed dude
it's illegal
and i still don't smoke we we went
through all this with george i'll make
you roll your [ __ ] cells right now i
bet you see a couple of stigma tracks
right there doing that because i was a
cop between you when i first became a
cop smoking a single joint was a felony
yeah and so on your own change oh not me
without passing it as a felony and so
you know i went through all this
today i cannot touch the stuff
because just for the stigma you know and
i'm not a prude i don't care who smokes
who doesn't
uh it's none of my business
now i will tell you without mentioning
any names
i asked the doctor once about this
ointment stuff
and he says
i get it from my mom
now this is my primary care doctor so i
started using that for my
busted up finger for arthritis right
here
and
you like that yes and it definitely
works i use sanasana we need to find out
how we can get that it's coming this
week yeah okay you ever been up you ever
been to salazar
you love salazar it's in right in in
frog town you know where frog town is do
you know where frog town is
it's great
dude
you got to eat i lived there for seven
years he's been more in the hood than i
have yeah
frogtown salazar yeah what about
esperanza
these are great i'll text you i'll text
you these spots dude
yeah there you go you get one of your
babes you take it you take her to
salazar you see it outside there it's
beautiful gummy bear a couple of gummy
bears you're a [ __ ] gummy bear right
you have a nice knife a gummy giraffe
they got the great they got the great
steak they cook it right there on the
thing with the real tortillas the the
yeah the the you know what i mean the
authentic
it's [ __ ] sick you know
yeah
send that chicken do you go to whole
foods or no do you go to a trader joe's
there
occasionally you know yeah is that your
is that your car the little
yeah yeah
it's cool i got one cute you got a mini
yeah i've had it since 2003 it's got 17
000 miles on it wow i love it it's great
right been hit by some famous people
[Laughter]
these guys [ __ ] drivers are coming
back hey man the [ __ ] car opens and
the truck didn't see it they opened the
[ __ ] door
because it's so little the truck is up
in that guy's [ __ ] hey we're here bam
that side of that [ __ ] car but
they're they're they're good they're fun
to drive they're fast yeah
yeah
easy to park there's a mini
mini [ __ ] i'm ready to get rid of the
one i my my cadillac the battery so what
are you saying about the marijuana that
not even the marijuana
but for what you're using it for it's
working yes for pain no no doubt about a
little score
either the
the little
chocolate
things that you the in the 80s when
people were taking pills or gummy bears
you know and i'm laying off the pills
you know i told the doc you know a
couple years they say i'm having trouble
sleeping you know i can't sleep he says
here take these you know he gave me some
sleeping pill i didn't like taking sleep
now
give me some gummy bears when i was in
las vegas after i had my surgery like
i needed some
i needed a diuretic so i told the lady
to go find me a doctor she found a guy
who we all know who was
on trial when
went to
the police doctor yeah yeah and he gave
her the prescription and then he said
allegedly
tell him whatever he wants
i can provide it for him wow and he went
through he needs
soma
uh
trapazine
and then the third one he said liquid
cocaine
and i said to her after my swelling goes
down let's all let's go get some [ __ ]
liquid cocaine those long schwabs and
how was it i haven't i've had it before
it's delicious
no he's out
do you see michael jackson at the store
[Music]
everybody went who didn't go there
everybody was at the store weren't they
they were all there
i saw
david letterman there 79.
all the big dudes david brenner
pryor and his rolls royce outside
brenner said something the funniest
thing that ever stuck to my mind still
today riding the the trains and uh
sit on the paper yeah
remember that he's sitting on the paper
because the seats are so dirty he says
excuse me are you reading that he says
yes i am set up turn the page and set
back down
[Laughter]
would you open a club in vegas no
there was a comedy store in vegas wasn't
there yeah in the 80s 80s yeah yeah the
dunes and the dunes yeah that was wild
that's where chris rock and i first
started yeah the dunes was a good it's
right there where the bellagio is now uh
they had their own little golf course
there on the side of the floor
nothing looks the same over there like
it used to
can the raiders survive in las vegas
without
it comes in three you know when they say
it comes in threes can they can they
survive without a wide receiver can they
recycle without a draft
pick
and the dude with the gun that's it it's
a wrap that's good now
they got out of the way
man i think guden's gonna sue the nfl
really really
wow
because he's the only one that
he felt like 650 000 emails and only his
three wow you got looked at
not that you know not that
but no totally he totally felt like a
fall guy for that stuff like we'll just
put it all on him and then fire him so
do you play golf
so do you play
never played
i've played i don't play
not my thing
i don't really have any hobbies
well i think
i saw your
you got a few hobbies
i think
[Laughter]
he loves the ladies but but in in in the
comedy clubs for you you see some
[ __ ] amazing looking
civilians
especially in this town or across
america do you think i mean i definitely
know
you talking about riding the fence
you see some amazing civilians yeah
you see some
that way you don't lose that they don't
want to at the end of the night you're
they're available but they don't want to
get involved with us if if any woman is
smart and there's a woman out there
whose boyfriend is a comedian
you go or he goes because you're not
gonna stay together
right it's tough it's tough seems hard
yeah because he's gonna be gone and if
you don't go then you're gonna think
he's [ __ ] somebody and then you don't
want your chick watching your act every
night either that's terrible
there was a story of uh a comedian and
his
wife brought her parents to see the guy
the guy was eating it
and he and she stood up and in the room
and she looked back at everybody she was
what's wrong with you guys this stuff's
funny
who said this the wife or the wife said
it to the audience oh really
wow
that should all that's what we're all
going to imagine i i've tried saying
funny stuff sometimes my wife has been
there and her feelings have been hurt so
i
just cancel culture at home you get
vaccinated yeah yeah which one i got uh
aderna and pfizer you got both i have
the booster oh really you know anybody
that's at it
passed
that died yeah
um
no
no but i mean it had some people that
friends that got it they got [ __ ] up
from it it's [ __ ] up i've had friends
two brother-in-laws
just
that they went and i've had two of my
daughters
have had it and survived they were both
vaccinated so everybody gets a flu shot
nobody gets vaccinated that's it
i don't know
both doesn't make sense i i would do it
i don't think it's a conspiracy i don't
think they're going to chip me or
know anything about me you just want to
be healthy for you
so what out raises you
you you write it down okay it's a
conspiracy theory don't do it
you do it and you save a life i mean
it's my life
do you have an obligation to your
employer to do it
i have an obligation to me that seems to
be the one like the guy aaron aaron
rodgers uh got it right yeah yeah that
was a big news story this past week him
and his comments well he said he'd been
vaccinated he didn't say with what well
he said he was immunized immunized
is
yeah i didn't i didn't understand that
because if you think about it you got
kyrie irving in
what is it in brooklyn oh yeah he didn't
he didn't get vaccinated and they didn't
let him play so aaron rodgers didn't get
vaccine and they let him play
no he didn't play did he no no yeah he
had played he'd played the whole year up
until up until last year but he's not
playing now and he may not play this
week yeah just because of that yes so
he's he's willing to like
i don't want to say mess up his season
right not participate yeah yeah based
off of the vaccine because he was
unvaccinated he has to be out for at
least like the 10 days from when he
tested positive so like if he was
vaccinated he would have definitely
missed like sunday's game but would be
back this next week because he wasn't
vaccinated he's got to be out longer so
he is planning on coming back yeah but
he's it is
kind of gnarly that the government is
basically
and especially our state of california
is basically saying yo
you have to do this or you can't work
you know like i went to starbucks this
morning on sunset in fairfax and they
asked you know obviously you have to
wear this the whole thing but they asked
for my vaccination card
at starbucks
they don't do that in vegas they don't
do it anywhere anywhere
a couple of things bothering me right
now wow they they ask for your
vaccination card okay i'm vaccinated but
now l.a city is put out so now because
kids are available now the kids have to
be back vaccinated so how do you go out
to a
dinner with your children
and if they haven't had the opportunity
to be vaccinated yet they haven't been
taken forward schools haven't mandated
it yet
so we have a problem that's problem
number one the other problem i have is
me next to you no not at all not at all
i mean i'll brag about this when you
were closer i'll brag about this one for
for years
uh
and and and that's the truth thank you
thank you i i sat there and called my
wife weeks when my battery broke down i
already had
good job my wife
i called her i said okay come give me
your car you sit here with my car i'll
take your car and i'll come to george
she was in a heartbeat and then i called
her i said forget it they got here
so
they met me changed my battery so you're
going to marry triple a i'm going to
marry you it's good for her to do one
thing a day don't you think yeah don't
want to press her
so the other thing is
now
well i'll say lapd sheriff's department
any
anybody local they're mandating yes
vaccine and if not you're going to lose
your job yes but yet
people that are
getting food stamps that are on welfare
on any other benefit why don't you just
say what you want to say they're not
being they're not being ordered about
that i just don't just say it yeah
they're not so there's there's something
there's a disparity there
how are we going to enforce this how are
we going to do it
and they're just going to do it do you
think it's ever been cool to pull food
stamp out i don't think so no
no i don't think they and i'm not trying
to take anything away from them you're
there and you're like no how much is it
let me see and it's nothing against them
i just don't think they're being so hard
on it employees and not just cops any
employee
yeah you know why are they mandated to
do it but this other side of society is
not
if you give people a choice you're going
to create an issue because some people
are and some people aren't sure but
it went away for a little while then it
came back stronger and it'll come back
stronger again if and i don't care who
is it who is or who is it
i am my family is so i don't care about
everybody i'm just saying there seems to
be a disparity on the way they're
presenting this
to everybody this comedy store haunted
um that's what i heard you never heard
anything in there i've never heard it
but i haven't experienced it you've been
downstairs to that yeah the basement
yeah cause there's a little what's in
there like a porthole and stuff some of
my old porno magazines
i want to see there used to be a uh uh
a tunnel right
i mean i guess if that's what you say
i'll go with you no there is i think
that well your family owned it but they
said there was a way
out well years ago it was cyros yeah
yeah so that was a gangster that was a
gangster place all the
actors in the 50s
60s
and then i know a woman that lived
on sunset in a big house that
was shirley temple's house and she the
gangster that owned it had uh
uh he had a tunnel running under
that he he'd come out across that's [ __ ]
i've never even heard that
that's crazy i don't think i had a bank
safe from the bat in the bottom of the
house
a full-on
[ __ ] wells fargo
[ __ ] safe those things
banks are not impressive to me i when i
was going to college i had to do a
diagram you know prepare for bank
takeover you know how was i going to do
this cops ambulance everything
everything's set up
and so
i picked the bank that i was going to do
with that and i went into the bank
and
i thought there was going to be big
vaults you know big this big
that ain't [ __ ]
no you don't even really see any money
anymore no right people don't take cash
it's all apple pay
there was nothing there it was easy to
do a
i got an a on my paper
salazar were you doing you're doing a
book right would you do a special
the why did you write a book i'm doing
it good yeah i'm doing all that [ __ ]
right now good yeah i got the one man
show and the book and documentary series
and uh
uh my band i have a band in vegas which
is cool where do you play we play
everywhere what kind of band
it's we just do covers you know but it's
fun
and it's like you know it's called
paulie in the crustys
and it's just me and these old guys and
we dive in and we sing these songs and
people love it well you know cookie jars
can't perform forever hey covers
yeah you ever seen cookie jar no you
seen them no oh man you've seen them
right yeah of course
he's got like the bangs and the long
hair and his
[ __ ] scenes and [ __ ] and he's got
everything now he's got everything done
with remotes
i just think i just think at the end of
the day what we do
um you just do you don't just do it you
don't think you don't you do this you do
that but but it's what we do you know
both of us are very fortunate and knock
on wood we're lucky we made it in the
early part of our careers
i am fortunate we've been sitting here
sitting here with you thank you two
icons thank you thank you but uh it's
true i mean we're very fortunate that we
got in and we made a name for ourselves
and we're okay now you know yeah very
fortunate because trying to make it now
it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] hard dude you
know i don't go to the comedy store
much but
i started there
this is where i first went on stage and
i was gonna jump into it but now forget
about it it was great and i love freddie
prince showed up and freddie prince was
before me yeah no i know he was awesome
yeah [ __ ] up he was [ __ ] up way
ahead of his time [ __ ] up
for somebody 22 he was already on lewds
and coke and alcohol and guns that's
what i was saying earlier [ __ ] man i was
just saying that these guys were [ __ ]
[ __ ] mine it was the thing to do no
wheat no no
lewds they stopped making
because
they were so good that they
said well i went to beverly hills high
school so we had quaaludes everywhere
you know what i mean you know something
i never saw when did you go to
where was that it was in the 80s here
you see yeah 70s in patrol never saw
quaylus
didn't know what they took a [ __ ]
black beauty once i'm looking like a
[ __ ] bumblebee it was that big yeah
[ __ ]
it looks like a bunch of people didn't
think it was a spot story
i would i would take pills i didn't even
need to know what they were from if i
saw the one in her drawer at the house i
would take that and just roll the dice i
said my grandma's got good [ __ ] i'm sure
this is
try to relax
me too it's awesome
all right dude thanks for coming man
i appreciate you hopefully the next time
i see you won't be at a comedian's
funeral that's right you know right
rodney a lot of people
we're at rodney's as well
yeah a lot of people there's a lot of
carl lebow carla bo another one he was
yeah he was with sam that time
man you know what those guys very unique
man and anytime we lose somebody i i
would say like we're all military guys
we're all soldiers in the same army
brother you all you are all brothers you
lose a guy
and the brothers just like the military
you guys are together you're very very
unique in what you do
and not everybody i'm not inside we're
going to stay over here because we're
more unique than you yeah you guys yeah
in espanol get away dude
thank you thank you thanks for coming
thank you sir thank you sir
the greatest and we're gonna cut
you where's your where's your one-man
show gonna be
uh tomorrow night will be at flappers oh
and then uh i don't know i'm just
putting oh yeah okay good i flow bro you
know just follow my social media
platforms i got all my [ __ ] there i got
my band i got you know all the stuff
trustees the crusties
and it's fun you know
it's all good all right man all good
awesome thanks for coming out
you